Do you need to write down what's with the jeans?
Okay.
Dorian,
Matthews,
linkedin.
Linkedin is helpful.
Twitter,
I mean it's fucking bullshit for dog trainers.
Um,
it's good to be back in the dome.
We are very excited.
I'm very excited to tell you that.
I'll be in Cleveland steamer this weekend,
Thursday through Saturday,
five shows at the great hilarity.
Is your go to Hilarides?
No,
I did the cloud.
He always did the dump.
If you ever go to
shit on the part of a massive premiere comedy.
No.
Is anyone talking about talking about the Rockland,
the Rock Climb,
Cleveland Rock clubs?
Yeah.
There's a rock club you can do stand up.
So,
okay.
Linkedin.
Linkedin is helpful.
I'm going to be there through Saturday.
Saturday is sold out.
I think Friday is pretty close.
Get tickets.
If you want to Cleveland,
I'll be there.
I'm going to sperm can and spread.
Campbell,
Washington,
Spokane,
comedy club.
April 21st through 23rd and then Jack me off.
Phil,
Jack,
somebody suggested and another one.
Is it in there?
It is right.
Let me pull it up.
Let me see.
We prefer to be called fudge packs and billions,
not jacks off Villians so I'm going to fudge packs.
Annville fair enough.
Strive is spoken in Florida and that is April 5th through seventh.
Those tickets are on sale.
And then boy did we get some suggestions from people about what is otherwise
known as Syracuse.
Those poured it man,
April,
excuse me,
May 20th through 22nd the 21st I'm in,
it was just two days I guess.
And Oh,
here you go.
Syrah.
Coups as from Damn Daniel,
Sarah's pubes and that's from Kellan sewer.
Pubes from Alex.
Yeah.
Sucker juice from John's guy.
And sorry,
excuse from Saks.
I like Sarah's peeves that Das pretty good.
Who?
Sara.
I will also be a new pork.
Shitty doing Caroline's on Broadway.
That's September 8th ninth and 10th be Trocadero theatre and fill her up.
Delphia Pennsylvania.
November 19th.
It's a ways off,
but those tickets have been moving.
I also added some new shows.
I don't want to say them because they're not on the site yet,
but I am going to another city in the great state of New York.
Ah,
that's good.
Um,
anyhow,
jeans.
What do you got this weekend?
April 1st and second.
I'm at Flip Harris Comedy Club and Sperm Bank.
Oh four.
Yeah.
Flappers kind of see me.
April 7th at the Irvine Improv and Irvine,
California.
Irvine,
Greece,
right.
April 20th 8:00 PM show at the Ventura Comedy Club.
Happy Birthday.
They who?
[inaudible] 20th.
Hey Hitler.
That's right.
May 27th and May 28th,
the comedy store in La Jolla and La Jolla,
California.
And also I'm at the comedy store most Saturdays at the early show because I have
a three month old child and I wake up at six in the morning.
That's what's up.
It's better to do the early show.
Anyone here?
What's wrong with you?
That's it.
That's what I got.
Jeans.
Oh listen to that.
It's deep,
Bro.
That's you go broadcast.com also Amazon.
If you shop on Amazon and I hope you do to make your life easier,
please use our banner.
Go to your mom's house.
Podcasts are clomp clomp dot.
Clam uh,
go to the home page.
There's a banner.
Click on it.
Do your job and you strongly,
like I say,
bookmark that
page,
make your life easier.
Do you know,
um,
our friend Jimmy,
our good friend shops on Amazon all the time
doesn't use our banner.
That's not cool.
No,
it's supposed to be a friend.
It's supposed to be and I know a lot of you are like,
oh shoot,
I forgot.
Well stop forgetting.
Please help your mom's this Justin.
Um,
for Syracuse.
Yeah.
Smear a deuce.
That's really good.
This one's from toilet tits.
Seriously at at Chalupa poop.
The name is toilet tighter.
Thank you.
Toilet tits for that riveting entry.
Smear deuce instead of Syracuse.
Thanks Barrett.
Who was as good.
You want to do this?
Yeah,
I'll start our show,
man.
That's why I'm here.
Well,
I'll swab and her.
Who's your dad and there we go.
That's my not my dad.
There is all this gossip going on about me and Selena Gomez and I have been
laughing the whole time.
Don't bring anyone loving
Christina.
We want to get drunk.
That was a little loud.
Wait Til I get my drum set.
Oh my God.
What a great idea.
Yeah.
Where are you going to play him?
I Dunno.
I'll put them next to my turntables and just kind of go back and forth.
How about in the baby's room?
You know,
you always joke like that,
that everything we get has to be in the baby's room.
Why can't I set him up somewhere else where I'm in that sitting room downstairs?
Yeah.
That sounds like fun.
You know?
What do you think?
Yeah.
I don't want a dream crusher so far.
Everything that I say,
I want to do it.
You go like,
Oh God,
yeah,
you got it.
I'm just that dream crusher wife.
Yeah.
I never say no to you.
So that's my turntables.
Oh,
that's different.
Why is that different?
Here is the only reason I discourage Dj,
uh,
Dad Mouth,
Dj poly by dad mouth is because you've already got a successful career in
Stanhope and now you're going to embark on a second career.
Yeah.
Hey Hitler.
Okay.
Yeah.
Are you saying why does it have to be a career and not like something I just
enjoy doing?
I again,
yeah,
go ahead.
You're always like,
you already have a career,
right,
so why can't I do it for not a career for you can do,
do whatever the fuck you want and no one cares and you're looking in the baby.
You're going to leave.
We're going to go down and see what,
why.
Nobody wants to hear you DJ in the House and just if I want to do,
nobody wants it,
but I want Dj was just headphones on quietly and another house.
That would be fine.
We don't have to go to another house.
I want to hear if,
again,
I'm not going to put it on a huge speakers.
Why?
Yeah,
why can't listen with my headphones on.
Okay.
Yeah.
God,
you're stuck.
You are such a dream crusher.
What?
Dream crushed city right here.
Okay.
Seriously.
It's really,
really bad.
No,
I'm going to get a drum set.
Okay.
Where do you want me to put it?
In your bedroom?
Yeah,
sure.
Hey,
what's up with this guy?
Oh,
I got it.
Wait,
that's wrong.
My headphones fell off.
Do you want to have to shit right now?
Do you have?
What?
Can we do this show or do you need to take your shirt?
There's all this gossip going on about me and Selena Gomez and I have been
laughing the whole time.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
that's neat.
That's really great.
What is that?
Why is that happening to me?
I didn't even know what is,
what's that?
What happens?
Well,
you know should happen sometimes.
Speaking of Shit,
do you have to shit now or can we do our show?
I know you shit 20 times a day.
I don't know if this,
this show impedes on your shitting schedule.
What do you think of your dad and Selena Gomez?
Not My dad.
I mean it's harmless.
I keep telling Selena not to worry about it.
I mean,
yeah.
How creepy is this guy though?
I don't like him as,
isn't she like a teenager or early twenties or something where she's not
interested in that guy?
You don't think so?
The way that he holds his microphone and he makes us like,
it's annoying to me.
I think he's in,
I think he's annoying.
It's one of those things like,
I will not let you blow me.
Like he's just making attention.
I want to talk about you.
Good or bad.
If a person gets mad,
they get teased more.
I mean,
me and Selena are famous so I don't talk anyway.
Then my 14 year old son Jacob Harris gets jealous and mad,
so I have to settle him down.
One of the things I think would be really funny though is to make a video like
this.
If your kid is being an asshole.
Yeah,
because imagine how upset his son if his son is a dick and he goes,
all right,
I'm just sick of you being like this,
and he starts posting videos like this.
Imagine what a 14 year old boy would do.
Terrible.
Do you remember poltergeist and that guy that God is at hand?
Oh,
that old man.
That's him.
I liked his guys laugh though.
That's still him down.
Okay.
I could see you with a guy like that.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I do.
I sometimes I,
do you ever do that where you see people and you go,
oh,
I could see my spouse with them.
I see.
I see that sometimes.
No,
actually I don't.
I just sickens me.
If he were to be with another woman,
I would fucking kill both of you.
Well,
I see a guy like this and I go,
I see Christina and him living together.
I see you guys making out like mouth smells so bad.
He has a lot of plaque on his teeth.
He doesn't do even by yearly cleanings.
Yeah.
His mouth is,
it's accessible.
Yeah.
It's all yellow and it's all dad.
I bet his penis is not the same color as the rest of his skin.
What?
I mean,
yeah.
What color do you think it is?
I think it's more yellow than his actual skin.
I think it's purple.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Cause if you look at the rest of him,
he's got a purpley tones to his disgusting gums and now it's usually the same
color as your penis.
I think he has a liver deficiency and that his penis and his testicles are
yellow.
Now I go highlighter Yellow Hughes detectives.
I wish we could find out the answer to this mystery.
That's the thing we really need.
Never know.
Well,
so you say my friend.
So you say,
I think it's possible that we could find out,
but you gotta be up for the challenge.
Yeah.
Don't burn broom broom.
Can I tell you?
I'm probably one of my nightmares is you getting guitar and then like Bam,
Bam.
I wrote this tune for Ya.
Listen,
listen.
And then you make me listen to you play the guitar and saying kill me.
I'm real real Beverly hills surgeons.
Yeah.
Oh.
And they had an outdoor thing and god is nothing worse than watching someone
play the Acoustic Guitar and sing at you.
It makes me so uncomfortable.
God,
God dammit.
And you have to act like that was really good.
Thank you.
I wrote this song,
they always tell you the rhyme and you know the history.
Um,
yeah.
One time a buddy of mine,
we went out to eat and uh,
we couldn't find what we wanted,
so I wrote the song.
It's about sometimes you don't find what you want in life that you end up being
happy with what you got.
Here we go.
It's kind of the rolling stones.
Um,
celebrity.
Nothing is worse than people.
Yeah.
Who is a vocation is guitar singing and writing songs.
I had to buy it.
I had a neighbor that lives underneath me when I was in my twenties that would
sing and all night long and he would sing one song.
So all you hear over and over,
it's okay.
Like the same shit over there was no one wants to hear you practice your fucking
music.
I think I found this moment still make me so excited.
Here we go.
Pretend like you're jamming.
Like,
yeah,
I like
this song.
But I like the dad.
Dedication,
dedication.
When it goes like,
this guy's my own.
Look how crazy.
When did he tell them what the songs are bark.
He comes home for a day or two.
It goes to for cell.
So this is a celebrity plastic surgeon in Beverly Hills.
The personal problem she,
she's going through,
which by the way,
oh,
here is one.
They could have thought of a more imaginative name for the show instead of the
celebrity plastic surgeons in Beverly Hills.
So they're all plastic surgeons by day and there were supposedly friends here.
Right.
They have a practice together,
right?
They have a big practice.
Yeah.
Part of a group.
They're part of like a a surgeon's group.
Yeah.
That's him.
So dad is a plastic surgeon my day and then,
yeah.
But as a performer to like to make you feel good and to bring an energy and joy
to people.
That's why you're not really a performer.
I really want to know.
Real performer.
No.
Haley's mind off of,
oh boy.
The personal problem she's going through and escape.
Escape to the music.
What's so different about comedians and musicians?
Because musicians can be really sincere about a song,
but like usually,
but comedians don't go,
you know,
I really just,
my job is really to make it really well.
Some do,
but not the good ones.
Yeah.
None of the good ones.
Yes.
If your aim is to make other people happy as a comic,
you're the shittiest comic dog shit.
Yeah.
Did your dog diarrhea
the blondes?
What's wrong?
No rhythm the other day.
This is so painful.
It's so hard.
You have to stand there and get hammered and listen to your dumb friends plays
hold all the good things.
And I remember he had a dedication.
And
where is it?
Right?
Robert announces that he's leaving for Brazil?
I don't think so.
Oh my God.
You know,
and he's following his dreams and we definitely get to vent.
Happiest are usually not so much shit.
Oh isn't this Scott?
How I know you guys are just here.
It's here.
It's here and it's like a tearful moment,
you know?
Do you want to move in with us?
You Love Daddy?
I don't have a daughter.
Yeah,
her life was here in Beverly Hills.
You know what?
Honestly,
at the end of the day we are always here to like,
we love you.
Oh sure.
At least when the cameras are rolling.
Yep.
Everybody's super skinny.
Come on Dad.
Tell us.
We tell us how you came up with this number,
dude.
Maybe we,
no,
I know.
Just look,
it's going to talk their look
their way earlier.
All right.
Right,
right.
I am all right.
The other side of me is like,
okay,
you're right.
You're right.
Sorry.
The search.
Um,
and the,
and the settings just beautiful.
It's on,
it's on mountain top with,
with this reservoir.
But low was the whole city and the Osha scarf distance and I'm looking forward
to,
to being tortured all my friends to shitty music,
which these mountains with them torturing your friends.
It was just such a nice evening and this beautiful house.
It was incredible.
Well,
with the view.
Very special.
Ah,
there we go.
Finally.
Okay.
Anyway,
I want to thank you all for coming tonight.
It's very special night for myself.
We're gonna play some songs that I wrote.
Isn't the
fucking Hollywood bowl.
It's everybody for coming out tonight,
right?
Could you imagine a comedians did this guys,
this next bit I wrote about taking a shit,
uh,
while I was,
believe it or not,
an actual shit of you enjoy it.
I wrote it to make you happy.
I read this guy does everything.
I can't wait.
Does it know,
wow,
what sucks about rich people?
Also,
by the way,
this is why when it comes down to it,
hanging out with rich people can really suck.
Yeah.
You know,
they have a to manufactured fun.
Yeah.
It's cause you don't want to like,
don't you,
there's tag along owners who they just want to be there for the free food.
Sure.
Hang out and they're never going to tell you,
hey bro,
your shit sucks.
Yeah.
But this jam out in a,
in a fucking trailer park,
it was way more on,
you know what I mean?
Like this,
this,
the equal party in,
you know,
in a person's $30,000 parking lot is,
is it's,
it's way better than the band who has to go up,
um,
you know,
and a pay or play situation or just like the band that struggles and does shit
holes.
It gets real reactions from audiences.
I respect that.
I have no hobbies.
I mean,
I just work,
I do it that way.
Hi.
No,
no,
no.
Anyway,
I'm going to want to start with one of my,
uh,
it's about,
um,
you get a little serious here for a second.
We'll sentimental.
You know,
I wouldn't what I do,
especially I spend a lot of my time as the document.
I'll walk in the room.
You don't know what to do unless you have something that's wrong
and you know,
but I think a lot of it is we get on in life.
We,
we,
we are that way in our days.
You know,
we spent so much time finding what's wrong about things in life in this,
this is a back yard shot of jam though.
God,
that's my whole thing is like,
don't you tell somebody that if they went to see,
like he's just playing in the backyard,
he's a Coachella in his mind,
he's headlining Coachella.
Um,
you know what?
I do think he thinks it's going to happen though.
He's like,
if I just put my music out there,
somebody's watching this and I'm going to get a record.
Somebody is watching this,
we're here to crush every musician's dreams,
et cetera.
But seriously,
like Nick Hock and this guy,
similar things.
Like if I put it way better,
way better was the worst.
I'd rather go to this concert than the Nic Hahn.
I would ask for an explanation of every song.
If I went to see this guy overseeing one Nicole.
Yeah,
me too.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Our full fucking two hours at over one nick hawks.
Of course.
Yeah.
This is pain
is actually called what's wrong?
Exclamation point.
It's really bad appreciation.
Supposedly.
Exclamation mark.
Are you supposed to explain that much?
What the song is about?
No,
come on man.
Nobody wants to take care of this guy.
Look,
you know he's young women like me and I liked them can,
it has always been that way.
Not to throw up.
I don't to see that my agent,
I end.
I rarely know how to please a woman.
Right.
Throw up.
I knew it was going here.
I got grossed out before it went there.
I knew this guy's an asshole.
I don't like him.
What'd you go with him?
No.
What would it take?
What?
What do you mean by hookup?
Let's talk about at all.
What about if you had to,
would it be him
or the mail?
Man,
you've already began a little something with,
with the sexy legs.
That's a sexy legs post,
man.
Yeah.
Well,
sex.
He likes post man.
He's like 10 years younger than this guy.
I know he's not there.
I'll Bob.
Bob is not 10 years younger.
Bob's way more normal than this.
Dude.
I'm not arguing that.
I'm just saying he's not a tenured yet.
Bob's way more attractive than this fucking dirt pig.
Look how dry and smelly his mouth and that's all you get because I can see how
it smells.
Look how it smells.
You don't know it is of course.
What do you think it smells like?
Dab Mouth or old rotten dad.
Man,
here's a,
let's see what else he says he's gross.
I don't like this guy won.
But why do you not like about him?
Cause he's a creep salad,
but you,
he makes you quiver like that.
He knows all this special tricks throw out.
Now,
honestly,
I don't care what people say or think we know that Selena thinks about it is
another matter.
Why was too short to take seriously all the time now about Selena,
my health has been bad for sometime now.
I know.
And the only person I hear from on a daily basis besides Jacob and Celina shy
the size to use your radio interviews.
Do you think I can't take this guy?
He scares me.
What?
It freak you out if he be pleased you in a way you've never been pleased.
Stop.
Stop it.
What?
It's so gross.
Um,
he's so gross.
Yeah.
I would rather be with a vegan vagina guy than this guy.
Whoa.
Holy.
That is a good caring woman.
Next subject.
Hey,
I don't like this guy.
All right.
So I'm just going to close them out.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Well there you go.
The genes power back to back.
Um,
can we talk about some important issues?
Sure.
Yeah.
Number one,
we finally watched the season finale of Downton Abbey.
And can I tell you something?
Yeah,
I judge people.
Yeah.
If they call it downtown Abby.
Oh my God,
we're not friends.
Yeah,
I know downtown Abbey.
Really?
You've seen it,
right?
Everyone's seen it written down.
And I know it's very clear what it is.
I hate downtown.
Yeah.
It's,
um,
it's beautiful.
You're so good of I love this is when the golden retriever,
they go to in retrievers.
Has He shown me this thing?
No,
I miss it already.
I'm so upset that it's over now.
We're late on this cause we didn't have television for the last three weeks here
and moved and everything.
Yeah.
I Miss Downton guys.
Tell you what I'm really upset about.
Let's go through the stories.
Let's go through it again.
What's the button?
The Guy,
uh,
but I don't like,
what's his name?
Branson.
No,
I like Branson.
Branson got chunkier.
Mr. Fuck in the gay dude.
Thomas Barrow.
Barrow's first of all,
I was upset that he didn't go through at the suicide.
I really want to Mr Barrows to die.
That's so horrible.
What,
what is up with you on that?
He was just such as shit.
It's like,
what does short memory be wowed?
They don't remember that Mr Barrow has tried to sabotage everything downtown.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
I'm glad you had a change of heart,
but I
not really like him.
I thought it was kind of cool that he came back and the way they tied it
together,
I liked it.
I actually liked it.
I like how everybody got a nice ending.
I love that Edith triumphed over Mary Anne.
In terms of status,
she ended up with a better love match marriage or just better marriage and
status.
Cool.
Um,
yeah.
And she actually overcame her continuous.
Yeah.
That was basically the theme of most of that episode was there like you're a con
and then they had Edith call her a cunt and then she saw her cantinas and then
was like,
you're right.
I really,
I agree with you.
I didn't know it was really nice and I love that final orgy scene at the end of
the
episodes.
So it's actually trying to pull it up.
Yeah.
Where Carson finally brought out his huge hog and Lord Grantham finally dropped
to his knees like he's wanted to for years.
It's great.
And Blue Carson.
Yeah.
Because the thing is that there's that scene where
it turns out,
I'll just tell you,
Carson has a bit of an ailment and there are all these kind of keeping it
hidden.
And then Mrs. Hughes says you have to tell everyone.
So Carson in like one of the final scenes,
he drops his pants and he has a fully erect penis and he goes,
this is what I've been hiding.
And then he,
he walks over to the all the girls and he puts it in each of their mouths for a
moment.
What's really special is the UK edition.
That's right.
Right.
You know,
not a lot of Americans got to see this one.
We paid extra,
but you get to see Carson,
he fucks Korah he fucks lady Mary flux eat it other.
Yeah.
And what I loved in the UK edition anyways,
I don't know if Americans saw they uh,
they gave cousin violet a pushup Bra.
Yes.
Finally.
They got to see her tits hoist it up a little higher than goes on,
usually hung so low.
I like rose goes,
I came back from a maverick
pushup Brock cousin.
Right.
Cause at Hogwarts it's okay if for Ted to that way,
right?
Yeah,
she just teaching.
Right.
But a Downton unacceptable.
Unacceptable.
Yeah.
Rose came back that little slut.
Yup.
She's got a baby now.
Yeah.
And uh,
her husband's not attractive.
I will say the roses way cuter than her husband.
I agree.
Do you think,
how's that going over there?
So we've found this in our home.
Next door to our child's room.
Yeah.
And our new nanny.
It was watching her child while I do this.
Yep.
I was trying to find that scene.
Cora.
Cora,
fish face always with the fish.
That's her face in every scene.
Every scene insurance goes,
I'm afraid not or I'm afraid.
So they're always eat.
It is everybody's afraid of feelings.
Yeah.
Though the reason there's never an emotional stake.
No feelings.
Is there any common those bowls
and then,
right.
You guys always go,
I should like that very much.
I'm afraid they're going to come out of your balls and he goes,
I should like that.
Indeed.
Yeah.
I should.
I should like that very much.
Carson I should like of that's interesting that they did resolve the,
the unanswered question of is there any come in Carson's balls when we found out
there is,
there's a lot of carbon.
Carson small.
There's a lot.
Yeah,
there's a lot.
Anna had her baby,
which was exciting.
They had,
yeah.
Boy
Is that Carson ejaculate in an area.
That's right.
I remember
right.
I almost forgot.
This is when the servants finally come upstairs.
This is a lady,
Mary's.
We're like,
we've been holding onto this for years.
Your lordship
ladies shift.
Everybody's happy.
It was a happy ending and down.
Really cool the way it is.
The Christmas episode.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and there are the you'll after you log Carson comes on.
Everybody that pays the black.
It's really sweet ending.
Someone brought the mistletoe and this is what happened.
You go chip.
Yes.
Costume
pretty good.
No,
I am upset.
I hear that there's a high here and Mrs. Hughes.
This is happy and Cora just came.
Yeah,
we agree that it's a really beautiful show.
Mr Barrels is either getting it on.
Yes.
Seriousness.
One was Lord Grantham,
his happy ending.
He got to see his daughter Edith,
who's just his whole adult life has just been bad luck.
Yeah.
Be Happy.
Um,
and then he saw Mary be happy as well.
And Carson came on her and that's why he saw Carson jazz all over his daughters
and then,
yeah.
Um,
And then he,
you know,
it was interesting.
He was one of the people he accepted the way that life was changing more so than
Carson because those are really the representatives of each of each I have
upstairs and downstairs.
Right,
right.
Carson actually wanted to hold onto it more so than his
Lord shifted.
Interesting.
I'm really had some really good observation.
Yeah.
Tom.
I mean,
no,
what I want to know is where do they shit and they didn't really address that.
He never gave us a shitting scene in all,
what is it,
six seasons?
I mean,
does someone have to wipe his lordship and his lady ship her ladyship they
probably used cloth for a while.
Right.
And then I wash,
wash his lordship's dirty.
I'm done.
That's an in Washington.
They ring the bell and the Carson asked,
where do they go?
Because they didn't have toilets.
They did a 10,
1850.
They did.
They must've had indoor plumbing.
That nice house.
None.
Didn't have outhouses.
Yeah,
they had,
they must've had some kind of indoor,
well that's our really,
Julian Fellowes knows the answer that okay.
Julian does know the answer to that.
Um,
by the way,
they would not sit with our backs to the chairs at Towlerton Edwardian Times.
Your Lordship,
you have no more common your balls.
May I leave now?
Okay.
Yeah,
maybe.
Sounds to me.
Okay.
So this is pat more than Mac.
We have something right quick.
I was telling you to sandwich.
Does he,
is that good?
That's good.
Always wants to eat.
Yes.
Oh,
whip up my basket.
Ah.
Oh.
Wayne's feeling his lordship wedding card.
It's true.
It does.
You're going to wear those tails.
Okay.
I love them.
My favorite thing ever,
and Downton is the time,
when was it Tom came back and he didn't have his dinner.
Tuxedo.
Yeah.
And they were appalled that he just wore his regular suit.
Well at dinner.
It's like what type of man that's,
that's really where it goes.
They're like,
yeah,
what type of fucking man,
what are you,
it doesn't travel with his,
you know.
Right.
His Tuxedo.
Yeah.
Could you imagine getting verse the Con and we found out it down.
It's all in Carson's balls series finale.
I loved it.
I just loved that.
Where's the cow?
Where's the con?
Yup.
I want to know is who,
anyway,
I'm glad we got that.
Now we are.
Our next order of business is house of farts.
Cause we haven't even touched that
because of the move.
Move.
Fucked this all up.
And by the way,
this is something I learned through this is that our wifi signal was not um,
strong enough basically in our living room.
So for those of you that don't know that we were retarded like me,
uh,
you can get a little thing called a Wifi extender and you plug it right into
your wall and it boosts your signal game changers.
So cool.
What a,
and it goes like a little gadget.
That's all we needed,
which we bought on Amazon through our banner.
Your Mom's house?
I did.
I did have
really fun time discovering it.
I called Time Warner who we have our Internet service from because they're the
only provider here,
which really is cool.
How they
monopolize and it's a monopoly.
Sorry,
professional Tom.
It's your daddy.
You don't want to answer it.
He knows my dad cause I saw it.
Oh,
where did it come up there
like Carson came.
So my,
um,
I called them and I said,
you know,
I'm having trouble with the Internet.
And they go,
okay,
well we'll send somebody out.
So the guy comes out,
he comes into this room,
which is our studio office,
and he goes,
uh,
so what's the problem?
I go,
well,
you know,
it's working great here,
but in the living room it isn't great.
And he goes,
okay.
So it doesn't really say anything.
A few minutes later I see him in the living room.
He's got the router in his hand and I go,
so what are you gonna do?
He goes,
we'll plug it in here.
That way it'll be strong in here.
And I go,
but we'll only be a week in the office then.
And he goes,
probably
cool.
Problem solved.
I don't know what the problem this time I'm going to go,
what are you complaining about?
So what should I do?
I mean it shouldn't I do like should I get a second router or should I get that
Wifi senator?
He goes,
oh,
those extenders work.
Great.
She got one of those.
Hmm.
And I go,
okay.
He goes,
I'm going to go put it back in the office.
Then I go,
okay,
thanks for coming.
So he put it,
plugged it back in where it was and then he left.
Cool.
Thanks for coming.
Time Warner.
Yeah.
Excellent.
Excellent company by far.
My least favorite,
uh,
Internet and cable provider.
We're not getting their cable service by the way.
Uh,
uh,
fuse that I've had time Warner cable.
It is garbage dog shit.
Yeah,
we're just doing apple TV right now.
Cut The cord man.
Cut the corner.
And we had time Warner and I thought we'd never have to dog shit,
but when we moved we had to fucking horrible time Warner's dog shit.
They always have the worst.
So disappointing.
It's just the worst customer service.
Oh yeah.
They don't just don't take care of you.
Um,
speaking of bad ass fuckers and shit like that,
stuff like that.
Oh,
these are crazy legs.
Um,
our good friend,
crazy lokes uh,
who I think is open to working out with me if I go to San Jose,
he has a freestyle rap here in Spanish.
Is that correct?
It's in Spanish.
So that's kind of my forte.
That's going to see what it sounds I haven't heard of yet.
Do you want to hear it?
Uh,
do I have a choice in the matter?
All signed quite low.
Small speed.
Well not time,
but the
mommy's
mommy's way towards them.
That would be so
nice
towards nominees way me sake.
It is all this cis class near this.
He thought your map,
somebody speaking in tongues before,
like in a church when they heal them and they're like [inaudible].
That's basically what
he's like.
Momma,
same Momma Sam a Macusa is basically that jibberish raise jibberish with,
with like a word in Spanish in every sentence.
And mostly because I'm not,
I don't speak Spanish like you do fluently.
I don't,
but I know enough like la Spanish to get,
and I don't understand what the fuck this guy's talking.
He's Filipino so he knows how to pronounce the words
he and their Spanish words in his
language.
But that's the package.
It's a FedEx package is here.
Does anybody says this dog is the worst duck.
We want a dog.
It's a Brussels Griffon.
Beautiful little girl.
Really sweet animal.
You'll see her in a pillow case floating down the La River at about,
um,
go ahead and pick that up.
It's your dog or with your dog.
She might be on the four oh five freeway.
Yeah,
at the Santa Monica exit.
just waiting,
just kinda hanging out.
God,
can I tell you what this dog,
if anybody out there,
if you're a real dog trainer,
and don't fucking email me if you're not legit.
Our doggies,
everything in the backyard.
And I mean,
everything,
rocks,
glass pieces.
She's indiscriminate.
I'm mean it,
and we're lucky she still alive frankly.
Uh,
but now whatever the fuck she's eating in our backyard has given her diarrhea
and she's had diarrhea twice in the last two weeks,
and he goes,
we don't know what to do.
Either we muzzle her when we learned about or what area.
Yeah,
but I don't know how to keep her from eating.
Whatever the fuck it is.
And it's everything.
Everything and anything.
Yeah.
I don't know what to do.
I'm at a loss.
Yeah.
She's worse of a fireplace so we can put her in there.
Here's your new Craig.
Get in the grade.
Gonna be,
Hey,
we're going to turn it on.
She would just go,
no,
she wouldn't eat the fire.
She went
up and we turn on the fireplace.
She went right up to it and was like,
yeah,
she almost did start looking.
The Flyer,
she's so inbred and stupid.
Gorgeous dog,
designer,
dog.
Dumbest dog.
We ever had.
Fee from Downey,
from the streets.
Smartest,
never runs away.
Wouldn't dream of running away because he knows how hard it is.
No.
Anyway,
I
Culito's are delicious.
Taco Bell,
his crew there is enjoying him.
Right.
And I laughing.
They're laughing at him.
What's some of the hair there?
It's called the kiss.
It's a lot.
It's hard.
It's hard to,
there's a lot of shitty music on this show today.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's been awhile.
We have to keep it short though.
We don't want to enrage the lessons up.
Greg,
from that for a second.
This I discovered was sent,
um,
yesterday as I was kind of going through these clips with blue man and,
just check this out.
This lady,
she's pretty great men.
Uh,
lifting weights at a weightlifting meet.
Okay.
[inaudible]
that she's awesome.
That was Grad.
That's not a normal scream for weightlifting.
And I like it though.
She is hilarious.
She lifts a second time and you wouldn't believe it.
She's back to screaming.
[inaudible]
only other time I've heard a woman scream like that is when you make number two.
I can hear you throughout the house,
the house.
And I grabbed the ball.
I got it.
I've heard it a few times.
When we had Korean BBQ,
we ordered Thai.
I hear you in there
when I was in labor and I cursed a lot.
Yeah.
[inaudible] this
lady cause all the Nice nurses were like,
hmm.
I was dropping f bombs,
dropping racial slurs.
Uh,
by the way,
that reminds me,
uh,
my cousin Julie chimed in on the nick hoc tattoo thing.
Oh yeah.
Let me read you what she,
she has a lot of tattoos.
He knows a lot about
the world attachment.
Hold on,
let me find what she has to say.
What was the reason we're doing that from a lacroix?
Yeah,
it's Lacroix.
Laquan.
It's not like why it's,
look,
I took French,
I took French.
It's liquid.
It's French.
I spent time in valley.
I have a lot of Canadian friends.
Is the national language.
It's Lacrosse.
Like Woah.
No,
the,
Oh,
I x is oil.
It's not like quiet,
not quiet.
You're retarded.
Delicious.
It's not only quiets lacroix.
See
now this is lacroix.
Sarah,
Eh,
Spec tech
syllabi.
Eh.
All right,
look what it's Lacroix Lacroix.
Quiet.
Not Quiet.
Okay,
here it is.
[inaudible] here it goes.
She writes my cousin Juliet.
I was always confused about what the Hell Nick Hawks Tattoo on his shoulder was.
It's where we should,
oh yeah,
let's bring it up,
ladies and gentlemen.
Comedies.
Ooh,
yeah.
I say,
Oh,
this is a good
image I think to use for what we're discussing.
Let's see.
Eh,
there is,
how do you say,
look at this mother fucker.
What are you doing dude?
What is that?
So that's what I asked her about because,
so you should set some context.
You'd,
your cousin has a lot of texting and her husband Justin,
they are like,
I would consider them tattoo aficionados.
Sure.
They both have a lot.
Julie has a lie,
tattoos and she,
you know,
she hangs out in that community.
She knows the folks.
You're talking to yourself.
She knows a Turd when she sees she knows turtle.
Yeah.
Totes.
And so,
um,
I thought it was a bad cover up on his shoulder as well.
I was like,
oh,
is he covering up something shitty?
And she thought it was a poorly executed cover up.
The closer she says,
I look at it,
the more I think that it's a poorly executed venom transformation tattoo from
the Spiderman comics.
If I'm cracked,
it's supposed to be the black goo that encapsulates someone and turns them into
the venom character.
If you look closely at his elbow in certain,
you can clearly see the sharp pointy teeth that venom has c.
Right.
So,
um,
it's like when that character,
that venom character,
it's like it grows on you and takes over you.
That's the thing.
Yeah,
it looks really cool.
It doesn't look Douchey at all.
And I liked it.
It's,
there's more here.
It's down the hip.
It's horrible.
And I'm not a tattoo aficionado whatsoever,
but they're also dumb.
Oh my good night,
Irene.
Really?
Oh,
that guy's got better tat
there we are.
I mean,
look,
I just,
I feel like they're super lame thing.
Think about him and he's just a guy that takes himself too seriously.
That's why.
Yeah.
That's kind of sucks.
And he's got the venom stuff growing over his,
his cock and balls,
missy.
That's what she's talking about.
You know,
and then it takes over you.
I mean,
that's too seriously.
That's why it's lame.
Yeah.
Way Too seriously.
Please let us know.
How do you click out of this?
God Damn it.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a lot.
It's just not,
they're not cool to.
And as far as I know in the tattooing world or he had shoes coolants,
like that guy has got like tough one's kind of cool.
You know,
there should be some skulls,
right?
There should be some bloody hearts or something.
Like my cousin,
she's got like some fucking dope ass chess piece with like a heart and you know,
cool,
cool stuff.
Spider webs on elbows.
That stuff's cool.
Then knock all tats.
I'm a huge fan of knuckle Tad's well this is like whack.
I feel like his study girl get your life.
Oh boy.
Everything about him is,
oh boy.
Yeah,
I'm working on my raps.
Poor guy.
You know my kid and there's a lot he's suffering inside.
All right.
Um,
Lino and there you have it.
That's so thank you cousin.
Julie.
Can I,
um,
try something real quick?
Yeah.
Well since we're talking about,
um,
Lacroix,
hey,
rob Ford died.
I know we liked him.
We like making fun of him on their Shell,
Babe.
No,
we did.
We talked about it on I,
she played him a lot because he was hilarious.
Yeah.
Yeah,
he was,
um,
it was sad though.
I was convinced as soon as I heard that he died,
that he,
uh,
that he died from an overdose or a heart attack.
I didn't know he was fighting cancer.
I didn't know that either.
Yeah.
I would think it would be drugs or something.
It's really sad.
He did lean that direction and we lost Gary Shandling too.
That's really sad,
man.
I love the Garry Shandling show was a kid.
Oh my God.
And the Larry Sanders show.
That was amazing.
That is comedy gold.
If you guys want to really dive into a
show and you haven't seen the Larry Sanders show,
it's fucking incredible.
Now it's real.
Oh Hey.
Now it's such a good show.
It really is,
are calling
donating with our flagship brand.
Okay.
Is La Croix?
Everybody knows that.
Not like Qua Lacroix.
Cool.
Alright.
The answering,
how are you calling?
Begin speaking after the tone.
Then hang up when you were finished or press any key for further options.
Who is this?
Right?
I was calling the quiet,
it's,
lacroix has called them to talk to them about it.
It's like dammit.
It's like,
why are they on France time?
Yeah.
Because they are in L'aquila wait,
isn't this like Canadian though?
Like French Canadian?
I don't know where they make product of USA.
Wait a minute.
Yeah.
It doesn't seem right.
Uh hmm.
So do you really making me Burp a lot?
I don't know if I should be drinking these as often during the show.
This is the most I burped.
I feel like,
I don't think it's good
potato.
Patato Tom.
Uh,
so that's what your mom's house is based on.
Burps and farts.
That's what we're about.
I should tell you this then in sort of,
you know,
we didn't mean for it to coincide like this,
but I shot a show,
a presentation a year,
more than a year ago.
Um,
where the focus,
like the,
the inspiration of,
of this show idea was,
um,
rob forward in a way.
It was alright.
It was a show called the people's mayor and we shot it and we kind of,
you know,
yeah.
I tried to,
to shop it around and they finally allowed us to put it on Youtube.
I just put it up,
um,
three hours ago.
It's called the people's mayor.
It was written by Tom [inaudible] who wrote for the Letterman for 15 years.
So he's so fucking funny.
This was a really good pilot and I really loved you in it.
I thought it was a great character for you.
I'm sad that it didn't get picked up.
Yeah,
this is a great show.
It was,
oh yeah.
Had Lung Cancer.
This is a,
gave her that same prognosis was 14 years ago.
It was that high remain cancer free.
Oh,
she died 13 and a half years ago.
Why,
why are you telling me this?
Cause it was like six months to the day when these doctors,
they all their shit,
it's great meeting a stand.
So it's uh,
it's on my youtube channel.
So if you go to youtube and just look for Tom Segura,
it's up there.
It's nine and a half minutes.
It's really well written,
really well made,
and there's great
actors in it.
Uh,
Joe Wang or at Marquette I love to play.
Does or a baker.
She is so funny.
So good in it.
Yeah.
Mark had been Jackson's one of my favorites.
Um,
there's just,
there's so many fucking here.
This little exchange here is really funny to me.
This is,
so I'm playing the mayor and he,
this is my island.
The Mayor of Detroit.
Yeah.
And He,
this is my top aide.
Like my basically right hand man.
And there's a rumor that there's a tape of me doing drugs and Oh,
and below.
And a black guy.
Yes.
Let's drink Jimmy.
Hold them up.
Hey,
can I bother you with like a work related question?
That dude's been in the bathroom for half an hour.
Just have his rank losing trunks,
relaxed public opinions changed pot is legal,
dude.
So you're smoking pot.
I'm not a pussy.
Cocaine.
You're doing cocaine.
No,
I'm not doing cocaine because this isn't ball street.
I do the real stuff.
Crack brother rocks.
Yeah,
you were smoking crack.
Medicinal.
Just little crack.
Could there be a video of you so off a black guy for drugs?
Black Guy?
Yeah.
Any,
any ethnicity,
Dick?
Yeah,
we're good buddy.
Look good.
Oh Hey Dave,
this is my friend.
I'm sorry.
I forgot your name.
Teddy fucker.
You forgot tiddy fun.
I saw that.
I just saw that I'm having a drink.
So anyways,
I really am like super proud of it and I'm so happy this isn't saying I'll get
to share it.
So it's a really cute,
yeah,
fine.
Emily.
Fun Kind of shadow family fun kind of show for sure.
It's just like that new full fuller house.
I'm glad they made that one instead of the people's mayor,
right man.
Good call.
I know shit like that.
And they go,
no thanks.
Fuller House.
God Damn.
Uh,
I mean I really feel like it's overkill today.
There's too many burgers
play.
Maybe my lacroix is not as,
can I turn that agreement is not,
was like it's too many,
but can I trade LaCroixs with you?
Give me that one because I feel like mine's flat.
How many burps isn't today?
You think we can,
we do a burb counter?
Yeah,
let's edit them together.
And maybe that's
many.
Sorry guys.
10 right?
Yeah.
Sorry.
I'll try to dial it in.
A crisis flat is mine right now.
How are you repping such big Burks?
I Dunno,
I've just always had it.
Do you ever pull a booger out of your nose?
So good that you think about it for like days after that
was so good.
Maybe not days after,
but yeah,
I think about them.
I pulled a booger out of our son's nose yesterday.
That was so massive that I've been thinking about it ever since.
What um,
what was it about it?
It was like just big and scroungy for such a small person.
Yeah.
I never pulled a book out like hard ones.
Sometimes you wake up and you're like,
oh,
what is that?
I got an a little edge are good and you reach in there and there's a fucking
boulder.
Yeah.
And it bleeds and that's a good one.
We got blood running down your face just from pulling a boat but out on your
face.
And you do just like when you go cat guy,
you,
yeah,
it happens.
Sometimes they'd pick so much that it hurts.
Like right now I right now so it hurts in their dug too much yesterday.
Um,
do you remember a few weeks ago we had the uh,
the twins and they were like talking at the same time.
Yeah.
We have a different set of crazy twins.
Boy,
they wear the same clothes.
They both have the tattooed eyebrows tattooed.
Yeah,
they are there.
They,
they're the same.
And they have,
they have something they'd like to share.
Hi,
I'm racing.
I am Anna,
Anna and Lucy.
Our job does the world's most identical twins
and they are both most Australian.
Where'd the other ones?
They were either.
Yeah,
a lot.
A lot.
Yeah.
They're both by a Nobel laureate,
inseparable sisters saying
you realize that this whole thing is a product of the Kardashians.
Of course it is.
Or Barbie like
dumb.
Yeah.
Well the whole lip Sula CellBazaar us is such a bizarre time will be like
everything's fake.
Yeah.
So weird.
This is the,
this is the standard now,
right.
And constantly cause videos of themselves to their youtube channel
videos to calm and their eyebrows practically the same from the hair cause men
to their post match your wardrobe and their magic asshole.
Same boyfriend.
You're,
they are on Australia's at sunrise show for us.
We've had separate boyfriends in the past and it hasn't work but now it's much
easier and yeah,
it's great.
[inaudible] we're with each other 24 seven.
Me and my sister,
it's just must asiatica shared boyfriend cause we're always together according
to Australian reports.
And if they're asked you in Darden,
what's with the eyebrows?
What's with everything with the lifts,
the eyebrows,
the wipes on your standard issue with I can't focus with the lips.
I can't focus because the eyebrows.
Yeah,
the lips are distracting to me.
I'm looking at them like I fucking don't know what's going on at the time.
But she just,
they just took sharpies and like the Chola brow cause they're trying to fit that
ideal.
They're there,
they're there,
they see the car dash and things and so damaged [inaudible] please.
So damaged.
Yeah.
No,
I'd be Bobby.
Yeah.
Seeing their future.
If one gets pregnant and the other will follow suit.
So their bodies stay exactly the same.
Yeah.
So they're both dating the same guy,
so he's dumping clips left and right on both of them.
I guess that's the only plus,
but isn't that the big fantasy for a guide to be bagging twins?
Yeah,
but this is the rare occasion where the trends are really want to do that.
Most twins go,
yeah,
they go groves and I want to have my own,
you know,
boyfriends elsewhere.
Yeah.
I like one person's come and meet like my own.
You don't really want to share it.
It like it's really private and these two are real.
I mean,
they must,
yeah.
They might even do that whole other,
like maybe they're like incestuous and they're just,
they might be,
I don't know why these girls just don't make the leap into porn.
I kind of feel like that's on the table that's coming up.
Yeah.
They're only there one phone call away from it.
Do you think they might be one phone call away from the,
the greatest porn leap of all time?
That no one's ever gotten anyone to do,
and that is to get them to be with each other.
No one's ever gotten that.
No.
I think with the thing is they've had twins do porn,
but twins,
you know,
siblings typically won't touch each other.
Oh,
you've thoroughly researched this genre,
like you've done the research.
Yeah.
And I think these two would actually go.
Yeah,
no problem.
Yeah.
I'll eat out my identical twin sister.
Yeah,
there's some of that going.
Yeah.
It's weird.
They're definitely a weird look how long I've gone without burping right now.
Can we just acknowledge that,
for instance,
shitting for that matter.
I haven't shit since before the show.
I know it's been a whole hour and a half since your last,
it's a big deal.
It's amazing.
Can we
RFCs want the twins explained?
They're not ready just yet.
We're on whether they're trying for identical babies as well.
Just imagine as I pulled up just as far as rent.
This is like the dumb girl dance till,
cause it's so funny how it changes every decade.
Like this is,
this is the dumb girl prototype.
Yeah.
And they're like,
you've got it.
You've got to check off the list,
right?
Yeah.
Dumb girl.
Hair check,
lips check,
eyebrows check.
Uh,
dress check,
check.
Yep.
Uh,
and the dumb girl move the party girl dance.
It's,
is there a manual that all of these people consult or,
yeah.
It seems like it in there.
They're getting loaded in the room.
Let's go shop fucked drop in our robot by way.
All stars.
[inaudible] dot com I'm the saddest shot
dancing in our hotel room that says dance.
Um,
well while that,
oh,
by the way,
last time we had a succulent Chinese meal.
Yeah.
A remix and we thought,
you know,
it was pretty good.
It was,
it's actually really good.
You know,
it had,
it had all the um,
like it's like,
uh,
I dunno.
Modern kind of dance vibe right to it.
Is it actually,
is it in the three,
six one?
I still have that up.
I don't know if it's in there.
If it isn't there,
I can play it.
Um,
it looks like I'm finally kicking in.
I feel like so inferior.
Inadequate.
Why do you feel that you've had all the verbs?
Jet Jaw hods off blog post.
Here's what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna get my Ted Stein.
I have to get my eyebrows.
Yeah.
Plastered in.
I got to get my lips injected.
Dao.
God thought loads.
Fuck it's not there.
Anyways,
we got a new one.
This is a totally different style.
Get your hands off my penis song.
This one's really good and really different.
Do you care to hear?
I'd love to.
I love this guy.
Good your hands off my opinion.
US.
There we go.
Aw
Yeah.
Got It.
I give the all day.
It's really good.
Yeah.
That's impressive.
I'm really impressed with him.
Good job.
Blue Band.
Great jeans,
jeans,
jeans are so tight on that.
Also want to point out how long it's been since I've burbs.
How long has it been?
It feels like it's been a long time.
I have a gene dilemma.
Maybe you can help me with.
Oh,
sure.
I'm,
I have a gene problem.
Okay.
Um,
no.
My post birth body,
I'm a little fatter than I've been in the past and I,
I've,
I buy regular people jeans but I'm kind of like in this gene dilemma or
like the ones I bought her two big but then when I go a size down it's too
tight.
So what do I do?
I've been there a lot.
I've been there for years.
Like I'm in between sizes.
So what pair of jeans do I wear it in the meantime always there.
I know exactly what you're talking about cause one pair it's too high and tight.
If I were the lower size and then there are low and loose,
if I were the,
the the size of mine
can't do the low end loose,
I would tell them a little snug.
What I try to do is then you get something a little tight to little higher than
you normally wear it.
They don't tighter
and you just suffer through some tight hours and then it kind of loosens later
in the day.
But if it just loosens ever so slightly,
it feels like it's almost made for you at that point.
Then you wear it for a few days and it'll fit perfectly day after day.
You have to power through those really high and tight.
Oh there it will not share that with everybody.
But I started to feel bad for them.
But the thing is,
yeah,
you gotta be ready for some uncomfortable times,
but what happens is eventually it'll be perfect
cause now eventually if you keep wearing them,
they'll eventually get loose and sagging and I have to go another size down.
The thing is is that you just can't sit down and you're high and tight jeans and
you can't eat.
As long as I don't sit or eat those jeans feel it.
The kind of feel nice one,
they're high and tight.
When we were talking about this like Sundays,
you like your jeans extra high and tight and Sundays I don't.
Yeah,
I mean pretty much I liked him high and tight.
You know
all the time.
Nobody knows all the time but can have their jeans high and tight all the time.
It's pretty.
It's pretty much a lot though.
It's a lot.
Uh,
would you like to care to read some emails?
Yeah.
Hey Mommy.
Tom and mommy.
Tina,
a longtime listener.
Lifelong Dany Yak here.
I've got my denim and a bit of a twist.
My partner recently farted during intercourse.
What else?
Know how to feel about it?
Let me be clear.
This fart came from Brown town and it smelled like chicken cream,
mid flow into relations.
Just want to get you a,
your guts opinion on the matter and if coital farts are acceptable.
Fyi,
I have also asked Hiller about this,
but he has a reply to any of my emails.
Many thanks Mr. Reckless eyeballing them.
Well,
here's the thing.
Hitler doesn't answer your emails.
He only answers vlogs.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's kind of some,
some JV shit too.
First of all,
uh,
farts happen in relationship.
I think we hold them in during lovemaking.
Yeah.
I mean,
first of all,
I want to,
I just want to clarify.
I'm pretty sure you're talking about,
um,
somebody who accidentally farted.
I mean,
that's a big thing where we're talking about an accidental 40 and disgusting.
But the thing I want to also make clear is there's an accidental fart less.
You're a real piece of shit.
You forgive and accidental farm to the accident.
Now is it acceptable?
Well,
it's acceptable that it happened accidentally.
You know,
if it's a repeat or a deliberate thing,
that's a different thing,
you know?
Yeah.
We should make every effort to hold in your pharmacy to try to hold him for it.
I mean,
look how long I've been with you.
I've held in all those parts and I've had to Fart a lot.
There have been times where it's come close.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
Down to the fire wire.
You still hold it in.
You still hold it.
Hold on his best.
Of course you do.
Fuck my stoma.
But do you,
you still,
um,
do you,
do you then go to the bathroom and then
only,
or I hold it until we're done.
Let's say that I have it.
Yeah.
I mean I've had them where I go right to the end,
live over and then you know,
I know you and I have been making sweet merit alive and then you immediately
fart after [inaudible]
and then you go,
ah,
we just made love and I go,
I know we're done.
That's how you know are done.
Parts were done.
It's true.
It means we're totally done.
You're totally wait until our son cause you've been burping in front of him.
He's too young to really know what's happening but when he figures it out it's
going to be fucking mayhem in this house.
Yeah.
I ripped him big burbs in front of them.
Big farts to first.
Only Cuban knows where they come from.
Purpose.
He looks at me and I go,
ah.
He's like
the little jeans is going to pick up.
Some bad habits would change between mom and dad were going to get a lot of
phone calls from school,
your son and he farted and then he said,
dammit,
I wish I had burped at the same time and we'll be like,
well yeah,
it's pretty big deal when you do that.
Your son has been farting on girls' hands and then we have to pretend like,
oh yeah,
that is build really well.
He probably likes her,
you know,
he's tried to show her,
Hey Hitler,
mommies.
I was listening to a boring news story in NPR,
just a few hours go to immediately thought of you guys just as it was ending.
The story was about the current over abundance of cotton in China
and how it may affect the global economy.
After some talking about the price supply,
demand import exports to statistics,
some statistics are how to read two sticks of cotton who went on.
The hint that we as American consumers can expect to see a price drop for
clothing,
specifically genes sometime in the near future.
Since everybody knows that Tom and Christina are the utmost authority when it
comes to jeans and anything else den unrelated,
I felt as a,
why am h listener of two years to keep you abreast with this new information?
I know I could really do with some denim,
more denim in my life personally,
so it'd be great to see the price go down for a new pair of those precious ball
crushing jeans.
Shout out to FIFA Betsy,
and little choppy though.
Keep in mind tight later.
Mommy's Michael from New York.
Thanks Michael.
Oh,
if I could put a call out there.
Guys,
any ladies out there know of any really good genes for when you're kind of still
fat postpartum?
Me Some.
What are some good genes to make a lady look a little skinnier and who has a
belly right now?
I go to the gap,
but I feel like there's,
there was a brand of there.
I'm not aware of that I should be checking out.
They're going to respond.
Let me know.
Girls,
if you've had a baby and I don't want to wear maternity jeans anymore,
it's too depressing.
The Alibaba total region.
Any normal people,
genes.
Just like fat people.
James,
dear mommy,
Mommy's just want to let you know I no longer listen to the podcast.
Nope.
I am now a proud of viewer of your youtube podcasts.
Yes.
Scared.
I now get the pleasure of seeing my mommy's wearing it high and tight.
No longer do I wonder is chem and hot as far as the,
how does they say what the fuck's a sky punch or I bet they break it down during
that sweet intro,
which you do.
Thank you.
Mommy's for not giving me the option of sitting at home and doing a bowl with my
two main mommy's keeping them high and tight.
Jeff.
Good.
Good Jab.
Hi Jeff.
I'm glad you're watching us.
This is definitely for you and it made me really laugh.
Hey hillers,
I listen to your podcasts.
Found something interesting about Tina's dad.
Mostly about her dad's drinking.
My Dad is also from the old country and would drink a 30 pack a day starting as
soon as he woke up.
Yeah.
I grew up thinking all dads did this too and never figured out that he was an
alcoholic until I was old enough to drink for myself.
He would also send me to fuck off until I was old enough to drink with him and
cool enough to hang.
I've never seen her drunk or pissy or a,
yeah,
no matter what he drank.
It seems to be a strange parallel between our high functioning alcoholic,
Hungarian father's love the show,
keep it high and tight.
Tanner Tanner,
first of all,
that's a very odd Hungarian name they gave you,
but yeah,
you're absolutely correct.
Yeah.
It's normal to grow up with the dads I guess is considered quote alcoholism,
but if her dad's from the old country,
Huh?
Yeah,
it's just,
it's just how they roll.
That's why seriously,
like I remember in high school confronting my dad,
I'd be like,
Dad,
I think I think might be an alcoholic,
and him and my step mother looked at me like I was an idiot.
Retarded.
Like what are you talking about?
You know,
alcoholics are falling down,
falling down and pat and kind.
I kind of agree.
You know what I mean?
If you,
my dad got his ass up for work every morning at the crack of dawn,
fixing forklifts,
made a great living and had a great life and he never changed his mood.
Was He?
In fact,
I would even argue my dad doesn't drink now.
I would even argue he was more fun when he did drink and I kind of liked his
personality even more when he was a drinker.
You use it like,
Dad,
I want to talk to you about something.
When I was a teenager,
I had the audacity to try and uh,
you know,
straightened them out about alcoholism because I learned that Horse Shit at
school,
you know?
Yeah.
And they just laughed at me.
I was laughed at completely like,
what are you talking about?
There's not a fucking alcoholic.
Come on.
This will stupid alcohol.
Luke's who had passed out all day long.
Even I have an,
I have a relative that has passed out drunk,
alcoholic and even they were like,
she's not an alcoholic if you're just close to doing it.
I'm like,
okay,
okay.
Because all countries,
I know though that that's not correct.
Right.
You know,
the older I get,
especially in the business where out,
there's a lot of people that use substances and can function high functioning
yet.
And if you can function but doesn't mean you're not a problem.
Yeah.
You're addicted to something your,
if you're functional.
Yeah.
You know,
fucking Mazal Tov.
Good for you.
All right.
In Charlotte.
But in Sharla and Mazal Tov together,
all those things together.
Uh,
God bless.
Yeah.
That's so funny Tanner.
Um,
speaking of Hungarian,
uh,
the,
I think there's some Hungarian in this,
there's a wonderful site called he fucked that has over the years provided us,
oh,
I know what this is.
This is like one of those online community college college thing.
So they do a lot of great work.
Um,
so this,
oh,
there's no visual format.
Well,
there's a visual,
I still think it would really fly.
Oh,
I need tubes.
Well,
yeah,
it gets a little fucking crazy.
So they,
the guy,
the guy who really has editing chops,
he makes,
he blends of horrific things with.
Okay.
But I'm pretty sure it's
PAC
spanking around her,
but that was his.
Okay.
Right now
he has her,
he's,
he has her arms tied behind her back.
I guess he's reading a new pair of sound.
He's reading a newspaper and she's eating his ass.
Okay.
Shawna,
text me.
Maybe I can answer this.
Can you use this one so that we get,
I can show you something on this.
Okay.
So,
okay.
He's a,
Sean is a fetish
word.
Can you hear?
I couldn't hear it.
Okay.
Let's see.
Hold on.
No,
no.
Too much.
I want to say on a,
I,
there's sounds like there's friends
[inaudible] business tonight.
That's a business.
Do you like,
it's okay.
It's okay.
No,
I think it might
top
not a lot of talking to you.
I'd like to help you on this translation.
Right?
Hello?
Hey.
Sue can meld.
That's French,
right?
I think it's right.
But Goodbye Cordova is a whore.
Yes.
That is,
that is hungry.
But she thrived.
I think she's Hungarian.
Ah,
words again.
Okay,
so he's saying whore and that's Russia and I think,
or check or his mother.
It's definitely not,
he's not the core devise a Garren word.
Okay.
But the rest is not.
I don't,
unless I don't know these words.
It's what did you bitch?
Huh?
She's just Q bud girl.
Know that this will be a know me.
You'll not too.
If speaking to he's doing,
he was such a bad accent that I can understand what you're saying.
Really fucking brutal.
Yeah.
Oh,
what's today?
It's really too bad we can't watch it.
It's really a lot to watch,
right?
It sounds like a lot.
It looks like blue bands not interested in
I told to be interchanged.
Yeah.
He was solid for a minute.
He's never saw him like that.
Why do people do that in the world?
I agree.
Um,
this is another reason why it makes you,
I think the real can we discuss the real thing
is that two people in the normal people in the room are like,
and you think it's hilarious?
No,
I thought it was bad.
Yeah.
I thought it was fun.
It's why you're choking and laughing as of his reaction.
Yeah.
Two of these kids are having healthy reactions.
One of them isn't
what parts of funniest to you where she's choking or being called a whore and
Cordoba.
Yeah.
Good.
Was horror.
Yeah.
What's going on?
Hey,
good.
Whoa.
Oh my God.
Oh My god,
you're a
Google know Asian.
How my ass conformer fucker.
Yes.
Uh,
Sweden sour sauce.
Maria,
what's going on is I got it.
Asians.
No,
so it's two transexuals having sex.
Oh God.
One is
okay.
I just,
I don't need it in my life.
I don't know why you're bringing it in.
In my world,
there's so much shit I don't need to know.
Like I have such a finite amount of space in my brain and this is not
necessarily,
there's a really funny part.
So
Tyson age,
younger Asian person,
the Asian transsexual is doing the work.
Has the penis in the Bot hall.
The other person is,
is making okay.
Kind of racial remarks as she's getting plowed by an Asian transsexual.
Does that make sense now?
No,
I mean again,
I have such,
I am calm.
How my ass confound my ass.
Okay.
Yes.
Uh,
oh.
I want to see a sweet and sour thought.
Bang,
Bang.
Boogie to the Boogie.
To the Broccoli.
Balmy harder.
Oh my God.
Yes.
Do you understand me?
Fuck me so far.
Yes.
The Hey for young mother fucker
for young.
So I thought you'd enjoy that one more.
I do.
I like,
you know,
I like the top always.
Yeah.
I pulled away.
As a favor.
Thanks
Jane.
Challenging.
Daunting.
Oh Man.
My name is,
yeah.
It's interesting Tanner,
when I started drinking with my dad,
he really liked me when I was in my twenties with those a good decade with my
pops.
Yeah.
Wow.
Um,
so I'm going to play this song,
Huh?
Going out.
It's um,
yeah,
right?
Yeah.
Wait,
where are we at?
We're at 90 minutes.
Okay.
John with the Chong or bang,
your bang.
Diggy diggy charm to change a change a chain.
Tiggy tiggy how's it?
Good Song.
You like kid rock?
I never knew you were that tight.
Now I just,
I just remember that.
Yeah.
Oh,
I've got to do a filler up sealer shot cocktail.
Oh Shit.
We hired you Jane Chicken Cheeky.
Okay.
The fill her up.
Seal her shut.
So harsh.
So we need
new song.
It's not copywritten by Mexican Mariachi band.
Yeah.
Here we go.
So mission number one from Ethan.
What do you think?
Fill her up and seal her shot.
Here we go.
It's good.
It's um,
it's,
it's good.
It's like a version of a popular song though,
right?
It's like just just right.
It's like a tweaked or no death cab for cutie tight and then his,
his audio didn't seem clear to me.
Yeah.
It's a little hard to hear.
If that was fixed,
we need to get it fixed.
If we picked that song.
It's just a clear [inaudible] on that sing song.
All right,
well I still like it.
I like that a lot.
John submitted this,
fill her up and Sheila shut.
Yeah,
kind of all you need.
You know,
it's good,
simple and we don't have anything with a country Western vibe,
so it really differentiates itself from the other themes we have.
Yup.
I do like that.
Very nice.
This one's from Chris.
Let's see.
Chris is entry for fill her up and see.
Oh,
you like it already.
I can say the smile.
So you want her shot
filled,
build up still.
I've been steal her shot filled her up.
So you want her shot?
Filled her up,
fill her up.
She'll her side.
It's kind of like a crossover kind of new wave sort of feelings.
Ali,
please beg naps.
He made a,
that was,
that one was really good.
I thought,
you know,
I'm torn between the country western and this.
Yeah.
There's this another entity.
Wow.
It's good too.
That's a good,
that's the rollerskating
jam.
I like this a lot,
man.
Fair enough.
Good.
That's another good one,
man.
It's really good.
I like it a lot.
Religion.
Fuck.
Thank you Lee.
This is so hard.
Oof.
Who's this right here?
Who is this fucking guy?
It was just fucking guy
down in the dungeon.
I feel like industrial goth.
Okay.
I'm asking
these guys.
Okay,
great.
Great,
great,
great.
I'm,
I'm a fan.
Yeah.
I came the Bevy of talent,
uh,
amongst our listeners here.
P P P P P k.
That's fucking phenomenal dude.
Yeah.
It's just,
it's too much talent.
I don't,
I,
I'm Toblerone Matthew.
Oh,
see he,
he stuck with the vibe of the lag.
Feels more Latin.
Right.
Good.
Very good.
Um,
did you make,
did you resend me the,
um,
the song the,
yeah,
yeah.
It's in the crazy world folder.
Oh,
it's in the folder.
Okay.
So we have,
um,
this was submitted by a listener,
right?
Yeah.
So a listener.
Oh,
the push and anthem.
Yeah.
A listener took crazy lokes songs and helped him make up
better song.
That's awesome.
Good help.
Basically.
Crazy.
Lokes inadvertently has a better song,
thanks to all that,
you know what I'm saying is I don't see who it is.
Soundcloud,
this do me stoop.
S t o m.
E on soundcloud.
Thank you sir.
We'll leave you guys.
We,
we need to get,
by the way,
can we get a poll going for the filler up song?
We'll do a filler up pole.
Yeah.
Comment on the youtube clip.
That will come out of day.
Okay.
So we'll do a youtube clip.
That's perfect.
We'll do a youtube clip saying,
hey,
here's the filler up,
um,
contestants.
And then you guys can say,
uh,
underneath that in the comments,
the first one,
the second one or the,
if we have listeners,
because I'm,
I'm really torn.
Yeah.
These are great.
Decide I would love for you guys to comment on it.
So we'll do that.
I'm still me.
Thanks a lot.
Here is crazy legs pushing a made by Stu.
Me going on out.
Yeah.
So thank you guys both pharmacy next week.
Chris Lowe,
she's pushing from the training to the red,
red,
crazy low Scotty from the training
and it's sick
training wreck.
Crazy low Scott
train wreck.
And it's said,
you know,
giving me the bush.
Yeah,
we got to just keep
[inaudible] it was so right.
I do it.
So
let's say for real star,
try it up though.
For real style.
Just live in like a base
jumper.
Crazy loans.
The training to the wreck.
Got To
conduct training
and it's said
in the training to the wreck.
Crazy low
train to the red and it's sin
for y'all.
Entertain my fans.
You know,
craze.
Speed.
The Gal one time,
God bless her,
she got it.
She didn't stop any streets and stuff out here doing this is all the shit is
over.
God bless
Dj Ali.
Bye.
Oops.